I went. I went too far in Emancipation.
Really? Yeah.
And research and everything.
Just bringing it up.
I start to get teary.
Okay. Right.
Okay. It's like.
I wanted to. I wanted to feel the
degradation of slavery.
Okay. And I just I went I went too far
in it. And it was it's like.
You know, the level of human brutality.
What we will do to each other.
And, you know, I had to medal. I had
two chains on my neck and we were we
were working and.
You know, So I was like, I want the
real weight, put the real weight of
them, I want the real change, all of
that. So they got, you know, old.
Yeah. Chains and they so they put it on
my neck. And they were fitting it for
size. And I'm standing there and the
prop master went to put the key in and
the key didn't work.
Panic.
And I was like. And I was like, oh, no.
I was like, Will relax.
And I'm standing there and they're
they're running around and they
couldn't get me out of it.
And I'm standing there in those chains,
dude. Jesus. And like that, right on
that hyperventilating edge.
And I'm okay. I'm okay.
And they found it and they they got it
out. And I was like, you know, Peter
was the character.
He didn't nobody was running around to
get him out, you know?
And I just I just kept falling deeper
and deeper into that understanding,
like. You know, you know, coming face
to face with with.
That that level of atrocity and we're
out in the scenes and, you know, it
was, you know, getting called 100 times
a day, you know, by very good actors.
By.
Day, very, very good actors, exquisite
performers, exquisite performers.
Hey, man.
Yeah.
You we still acting?
I was like, Hey, hey, Cut, cut, cut.
Cut. Talk to you for a second.
You. Hey, you.
Your boy. Sharper since your boy.
They've gotten a lot sharper since we
started.
Hey, lighten up on that E.R.
Yeah. Can you lighten.
Up on that? E.R.
Just for me? Two of them.
F*** it up. I've never seen an actor
give eight. Great takes better than
this one on this whole set.
Not one of you guys have missed one of,
you know, getting lost in those.
I dream about Peter still.
Wow. Like. And that's what happens
when, like, when you when you spend
that time and you push your you push
your mind that far and you just consume
it and you surround yourself on all
sides by it. And that's what happened.
It like starts to leak into your into
your subconscious and now you're
dreaming. And, you know, I wouldn't
give it back. It was it was one of the
greatest experiences I've ever had as
an actor. It's like Peter introduced me
to God.
Right. Wow.
Like my faith got solid.
Wow. After working on that movie.
Wow.
Wow. I don't know about you guys, but
after hearing that, I want a little
more wine.